he's Adrian Peterson he Redskins running
back on pace for a thousand yards and
had another big performance 99 yards
against the Cowboys this past Sunday and
Adrian Peterson back on the program
how are you Adrian I'm doing great man
how are you doing doing I'm doing okay
how did it feel after Sunday's game with
the Cowboys
how'd your body feel huh my body felt it
felt pretty good you know actually I'm
better than a week before you know so
that was that was motivating but I still
still a little banged up all right you
look at your age now everybody starts to
bring up the age of a running back
usually what after 30 does that feel
like yeah yeah so much like Adrian
Peterson 33 you know that there's
something about that that you know how
much do you have left but how is 33
Adrian Peterson and as a 23 year old
Adrian Peterson like what is the biggest
difference between those two I would say
you know the football player just a
smarter smarter player you know they've
been through a lot of different
situations and scenarios but like
physically I don't really I haven't
noticed it at all how are the knees the
knees are great
the knees are great I never you know
people always ask that question too and
it's like hey I got some the other thing
is just kind of nicking you know just
kind of nagging me at the time but my
knees have held up great since you know
of ACL surgery and the meniscus tear had
in 2016
but what would be different now if you
were coming out of Oklahoma with how
running backs are used
mm-hmm how different would you be used
now in today's game as opposed to when
you first came out you know definitely
more versatile you know as far as being
out and you know running routes and
things like that you know but but I
thought I can say that would be the way
but the crazy thing is is that you know
that was one of the reasons I went down
to New Orleans to be able to kind of
meet that transgender girl was making
you know and you know those are things
that I'm care
full of doing and I shows there and you
know you know hopefully I have the
opportunity to do it here when CT isn't
out there doing this thing you know so
but that would be the change what were
you doing when the Redskins called um I
was actually just landing from Tulsa
Oklahoma
my brother-in-law we threw a surprise
birthday party for him we're not you
know as a group parents but so yeah I
was landing back in Houston and I turned
my phone gone and my agent I've seen a
lot of text messages come through my
phone like hey call call soon as
possible my dad was texting me and I was
going on you know you know called
talking to him and he was like hey
risking I want to bring you in for a you
know for visit and worked out and they
want you to fly in tonight thinks your
career is over
yeah prior to then not at all not at all
mmm no that ain't crossed my mind
favorite runner your career do you have
one favorite song on my career man it's
a good one I would probably say it was
against New Orleans in the NFC
Championship game and I was inside zone
play and I broke through the live like
eight yards and should be a home run I
don't know if it was I don't know who on
earth of Zimmer who came in and end up
not gonna ball out and the ball flew in
front of me like literally ten yards and
I remember you know in the moment the
ball is right there and I see like two
defensive players right approaching the
ball coming towards the ball and coming
towards me and next day I remember BAM I
was on the ball and that's one of my
favorite runs or my favorite place
because it was like it was one of those
moments where I just long there's
something like supernatural and I was
kind of like all my knees I call it you
know it's like how did I get to the ball
before those guys you know so I would
say that one game against the Cleveland
Browns great block by Sidney Rice end up
stifling
a guy shoving them out of balance almost
lost the ball kind of card with my
helmet in my shoulder passing and ran
into the end zone that's not bad I mean
you got a few on the list there Adrian
let's be honest who do you consider the
best running back of all time the best
running back of all time
Barry Sanders of course Jim Brown is a
legendary guy that started everything
for us but when I look at and I feel
like Jim Brown also could play in any
generation but when you do it when you
look at this scoring touchdowns and
picking up yards and no matter how you
did it and the short career Barry
Sanders had which it was it was long but
you know obviously he could play a lot
longer yeah nobody ever hit a made Rhian
yeah I know exactly so I would say Barry
Sanders he's Adrian Peterson Redskins
running back out the Giants coming up
next game I was wondering about this
does it bother you still bother you that
you finish runner-up to Matt Leinart in
the Heisman in 2004 you know especially
when the first freshman and you know
gonna start winning Heisman and stuff
like that I think yeah yeah Mike really
I should have been the first freshman to
to win a Heisman Trophy but you know
when I look over when I look back I'm
just like okay I've accomplished a lot
of great things you know Matt he didn't
have the type of career that you know
I'm sure he envisioned having so you
know he got the Heisman Trophy to kind
of you know make her feel a little
better about that but I do think you
changed the voting process because I
remember arguing and I didn't vote for
the Heisman back then but I would argue
with people who did vote and say why
don't you consider freshman and
sophomore I thought Marshall Faulk had a
chance to win the Heisman and you too
and that's you know Hershel Walker and I
said why do we make this you got to be a
junior or senior you're not being fair
to the underclassmen
I think when you came along and rushed
for 1,900 yards you open people's eyes
to hey
a freshman can be the best player in
college football so you didn't win the
Heisman but I do think you changed the
voting process you know and I can look
back and say you know what that that's
good you know if it opened the door for
some freshmen come in had opportunity
then you know it was it was a good job
by me you know what's funny about that
year as well I think me and Reggie Bush
were the only two running backs up for
the Heisman Trophy and I was I was a
freshman I didn't win a dog walker
awards for the best running back all
right you're not better you're not
better you you've totally let it go
right yeah I can tell
I remember you tell me you had a
black-on-black Bentley yes where is the
black-on-black Bentley is that long gone
actually yes long gone I'll get rid of
it what are you driving now well right
now I'm driving a forward a4 is for the
expedition I think wait did they give it
to you is that why you driving it yeah
but my car back home is uh s-class
Mercedes s63 okay all right like on
black with you okay I got one of those
black on black yeah those are great cars
now do you do the driverless do you let
it drive you I'm not that comfortable I
like to be in control so nervous I was
also wondering this too because you
finished runner-up two liner and Alex
Smith your current teammate finish
fourth in that Heisman race did you know
that yeah yeah yeah yeah it was um it's
cool guys thought about that since I've
been here it's like you know how things
can kind of come around full circle me
never racing crazy coming out of high
school if it wasn't Oklahoma you would
have gone to USC yeah Texas listen Texas
was already out of the picture because
Matt Brown said hey you know said
admissions coming back for his senior
year seem to be loyal to him you know he
started to the freshmen
he leaves and you could take off my guy
every other school telling me hey you
can come in and compete for the story
job
wait so you ought have gone to Texas if
Mack Brown says you can come come in and
compete for the job yes
oh man how close was you I see well if
they weren't on the west coast it was
close you know all right cuz Oklahoma it
was it was really close it was really
really close really close but then you
would have been competing with Reggie
Bush yeah yeah man Lyndell white dinner
oh my god yeah I knew all about those
guys yeah Wow whoo coach dude you didn't
have Switzer did you know Coach Stoops
okay we gon do you wanna bet coach no
that's right yeah I also was curious
about this with what like the evolution
or maybe lack thereof with the running
back with lowering your head that this
was supposed to be a big deal that
running backs can't lower their heads
but that hasn't been called very often
how come I thought they were gonna
enforce that this year I mean you're
glad that they're not I'm sure yeah you
know and I think it's just a natural
movement for the running back you know I
think it's more of a focus on you know
defenders you know and then blowing
their heads when they come into you know
to tackle guys but for running backs you
know it's kind of harder to lower your
shoulder pads you know that's right go
ahead I mean do you get your bell rung I
mean you get you know even when you're
lowering your head or you I'm sure
you're ringing other people's bells but
do you I mean do you lower your head and
get your bell rung occasionally that
might happen but you know for me I
really haven't experienced that normally
when I when I are you ready to lower my
head you know I'm seeing what's coming
towards me so I'm able to gauge you know
if I'm gonna hit this guy with my
shoulder pads you know and it's
happening so fast so normally you know I
gauge it right when I lower my head I
kind of know where where I'm going and
you know who's approaching me you know
so you can you can abort those as well
is when it's really when you got those
defenders
or you know kind of really making the
last move to make their tackle or guys
are flying in after you wrapped up to
make those tackle tackles that should
come in when they're faced with the face
mass up you know to prevent hurting
themselves and cause an injury to other
players if you could be any running back
in the league now who would you be
Adrian Peterson no no you're already
Adrian Peterson who's if I said I I can
pick a young running back you can be
that running back now mm-hmm would you
be a girlie he'll be targeting early or
Berkeley oh really
yeah dr. Lee's bad dude oh yeah yeah
there he is man I love that kid
you know he's humble hard worker you
know and you know dude I just love how
he you know Kerry Kerry himself himself
and Berkeley just watching him as well
man you know III can see it you know so
I'm just gonna continue to watch them
and overly long [ __ ] of course one
shutting down this week of course you
are sub corner down is weak yeah I'm a
competing to watch him for sure if I
talk to you in three years what are you
doing
probably sitting here in the same room
you think you'll be
you think you'll still be playing at 36
yeah what I want to do you know I don't
feel like you need to go keep me from
doing that before it's like talent or
anything like that so and if you loosen
up on your grip when you shake people's
memory we had an issue with this where's
man we did it
I kept you eased up a little bit some
DAP Adrian I mean that's man yeah you
are young people approached me with
those two dabs oh I would I wouldn't
shake I would shake your hand and not
out of disrespect I just don't want my
hand hurt it's just a little dab there
okay good luck against the Giants good
to catch up with you and we'll talk to
you in three years when you're 36 still
playing for the Redskins
I mean hopefully we talk before the end
but appreciated Thank You Adrian that's
Adrian Peterson Redskins running back
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]